[Music]
okay for people joining this live stream
sorry we're starting slightly light here
um the uh this is the design review
about uh well what are currently called
compiled layers but you're on that
framework they probably won't stay as
compiled layers for more than a few
minutes here but we'll see
all right so let's get an understanding
of what this is
this is oh boy do we have people from
the compiler group here
no but i'm not sure we would need them
okay but i'm not prepared to have a
discussion about function compile
without them
oh i mean we're not really going to
discuss the question compile we're going
to discuss everything that is around it
um yeah this is going to happen have you
looked at
christopher's new tooling for the
compiler
i did not and i don't think we're going
to be able to have this conversation
um this is this is you know
everything i put in this notebook
there's nothing about function compiler
except at the very beginning except the
very beginning
because the everything is about you know
the backward function the the you know i
mean there's a bunch of things to talk
about
about how to to specify the name of the
of the input port the output ports like
okay so let me just understand hold on
hold on hold on
hold on this is or is not using our
compiler
it is it is definitely using a compiler
but it could be a black box for us like
okay
but it's generating llvm code that is
then being run is that correct
yes yes okay you need to use this
tooling that christopher has been
working on
yeah i we were talking about that with
with mateo we haven't looked at it
uh but like for us if there's a better
uh packaging of this
it's great but it doesn't really change
um everything else
it's it's uh so the idea is to piggyback
on
whatever okay but so what extent is is
this compiling to mxnet code and to what
extent is it compiling to raw
compiling at all to mx netcode so
so there's two things that net function
that this one
is meant to be to be kind of converted
not to
mxnet but to our uh
layer so wait wait so this is running in
llvm plus rrt our rtl is that correct
i don't know yes yes oh yeah yeah okay
yeah
runtime library so yeah so this is not
net function right net function is a bit
more the high
level thing that will try to create a
graph that will try to convert things to
a max net
this is the lower level of stuff that
we give code it it converts it to
uh with function compile to lvm and and
whatever
and uh and and we'll use it won't
convert it like
yeah won't convert that to a makes that
it will just run
okay so this has all been changed okay
sure that's all been changed so it's no
point in designing something around this
that doesn't doesn't but
those things are only supposed to be
arguments inside our functions so even
if those the form of the expressions
changes
you know the representation changes for
us there are still
arguments i thought i had asked this
last time to make sure that if you're
using the compiler
you have people from okay whatever
matter it just doesn't matter
so i mean all right so as far as you're
concerned okay so you're telling me that
that function
could as well just be a piece of
top-level code is that correct
no absolutely so so thread safety
that's just the technical thing is that
mxnet starts many thread
right and our regular code is not thread
safe so if you you
you put that into mxnet naively we
thought we could do that at some point
uh you just mess around have you talked
to anybody about what it would take to
make
a version because because it just needs
a separate kernel right
you can't do it threaded into the
existing kernel but you could do it as a
separate kernel
it was not practical it wasn't practical
this we definitely talked it was at the
time it was started in sebastian
uh they were on that and and this is not
practical but the great thing
is why is it safe why why i don't know
why
i don't know why okay so let me explain
what i think they thought and i think
they were wrong
okay now okay
they were not imagining that you could
start a whole separate colonel
to live in that thread
i think you can but i think it's
starting threat all the time and killing
fed all the time i think it's like
hundreds of three i mean
it's super competitive machines how many
threads
how many threads it depends it depends
what what the form of the network is but
it's in general there's no limit
okay that's not useful to me tell me the
average number of threads running on a
typical cpu
the average number of threads running on
a typical cpu
you know it's do i need to run this and
find out
my guess is that you're talking about on
the order of because you know
it's not doesn't do you much good to run
more threads than you have
then you have cause sure but
you know i you know okay so so i don't
think this is a good
okay listen listen there are several
things that have changed
first of all we now have forking which
means the cost to start
a kernel is much lower
okay and it doesn't take additional
memory to have an additional kernel
started
i think we can do this okay this is
something that has been
i mean sebastian italy i've been working
a lot on that talking with everyone i
mean okay let's maybe some new stuff
but uh one thing that is sure that this
works
the the the compile stuff is that the
compiler works if the the compile stuff
works if the compiler works but the
compiler doesn't work well yet
that's true that's right so we're not
going to be able to do stuff i mean the
compiler right now
has a minimum run time of 15 seconds
roughly
which is fine if you're compiling
something once
it is not applicable to just in time
compilation
yeah which we won't do in that case but
it's yeah i mean actually that would be
nice in some cases yeah
well so you're saying this is something
where you would compile it
when it is created you know when it's
put in the neural net repository
and then it is not compiled again is
that right uh
no actually i think you're right it has
to be compiled um
okay that's not gonna work it's simply
not gonna work steven it's one
procession
it's not gonna work it's not gonna work
yeah it's true i want to load your
network when you load your network
when you load the network it has to
recompile why
no why
because it's the same reason why when
you load
a compiled function from a wxf file it
recompiles it
why maybe the technical way maybe
they're technically why
i think you're wrong i think what's
happening there is it's it doesn't know
the architecture that you're on
and you are making the mistake of
thinking that you can't have essentially
a fat binary that deals with multiple
architectures
which we can have it probably doesn't
compile to that fight binary right now i
don't know well
that's why you needed to learn about the
new tool isn't it
right but is this new tool
just only wrapping the existing compiler
is it a completely separate
thing it is tearing apart a bunch of
stuff in the compiler that wasn't well
designed
and putting new stuff in there instead
okay but and all right well that's good
that's good if
if i mean it's true technically i don't
see a reason why i couldn't just keep
the lvm
and not have to recompile every time
that doesn't make sense right
doesn't make sense so so we'll probably
find a way
okay so let's walk through the use cases
again okay
so i want to i want to walk through what
you're actually talking about first
point is
there are networks that involve raw code
that is not represented by our
existing layers and is not implemented
by the essentially mxnet interpreter
right those are things those are the
things you want here
things that are raw code that is not
available in the essentially mx
net runtime library is that correct
or that we don't have a um
no that's not correct you've got a
different mechanism
for dealing with other things that are
in the mx net layer but not
at our top level layer correct oh no
this is internal
this is not this is not uh okay what was
the thing you were showing me with net
function
so net function is converting code to
our
framework so it's actually constructing
a net graph underneath
and uh converging everything in our
layers and
uh okay so but i thought there was a
mechanism which we talked about
to access raw mx net functionality
like an assembly language yes but it's
it's undocumented it's called mx layer
it's internal okay why is it
undocumented
because like we've never thought about
documenting it it's it's pretty ugly
you know you have to deal with a lot of
mxnet internals
okay so so my question is this my
question is this the the kind of
wrapping that we have
um of that low-level you know
layer right can we generalize that to
other i mean is it the case that there
are other
or is it the case that other things have
just been sort of hacked into mxnet
and they have different weird designs
and they don't follow
they're not consistent with the kind of
flow for net graph and so on is is that
what the situation is or what
well mxnet has mx networks graphs
and they have nodes can you answer the
question can you answer the question
what i'm asking is
is it the case that there are things in
mxnet
that are design compatible with what we
have but simply haven't been implemented
or is the stuff that we don't have
design incompatible with what we have
i think it's more the second there's a
bit of the first thing it's more the
second
our thing is higher level than a mxnet
it works a bit differently
for example the weights are inside the
layer not not outside
now there's a little bit of stuff there
in the mixer that we don't have yet
and for example more imperative type
programming
and i think that that's that's what you
were thinking about when talking about
net function
eventually we want that function to be
able
to um understand so you've got a part
complex code
right but but so so what is your path
there
because what you're describing is the
net function right now
is compiling to our existing layers
that's what you're saying yes
yes yes okay you think that there's a
possibility that net function might be
able to directly compile
to maxnet stuff yes or other frameworks
always like
imperative programming type network so
things that don't that don't fit into a
graph you know you have a loop you have
statements i get it okay so what will be
involved okay to do that are you
imagining
because one possibility is that you
could
take the compiler framework with all its
type specifications and so on
and emit as the code generator some
different kind of code than llvm
yeah i mean
they have the you know they they said
that eventually you'll be able to comply
to cuda
which is awesome for us what will be
able to compile to cuda
our compiler yeah our compiler
but i don't understand okay i don't
understand you've got two paths here
you've got one path where you say
you're trying to compile things okay
there's three different targets
our top level layers mxnet
and llvm and other low-level direct
executables
yes is that correct yes yes
okay yes so
okay so what you have here is a design
for
wrapping for neural net use directly
executable
things is that correct yes
and that's lower level internet function
eventually i expect net function to be
able to handle a bit everything
automatically okay the concept would be
that net function if it encounters
something that can be
implemented as a compiled layer it would
do the compilation and implement it as
that
exactly correct exactly yeah it will do
the best
each time if you can go to the next
night okay okay okay
so now the next question is the actual
use of this
given the current state of the compiler
right so that depends on in my view
being able to have uh one of several
things
that clearly is architecture dependence
to the lvm files
right actually maybe there isn't to the
llvm itself there may not
be it may be just a last level
of llvm processing that requires which
is why you need to know about this new
tooling
right because that's what that's what
contains the
okay so one possible workflow in use
case is
you do the compilation once and for all
it's in the neural net repository
you download it and there are two
possible flows there
one is you download something which is
at the level before
specification for a particular
architecture and that specification
happens quickly
i don't know whether that's possible or
two
because the whole type analysis layer
cannot be run in real time
at this point am i making sense yep
okay so it's possibility number two is
you store well there actually two other
possibilities
one that i don't really favor is that
you you know you download a fat binary i
don't think that's a good idea i think
they'll get big
and i think it's a bad idea the other
idea is that there's an interlock with
the neural net repository which i think
is doable
where you simply request the appropriate
binary
based on your architecture i mean it's
not just a repository right
it's anyone that creates a network and
and and
and save them somewhere and re-upload
them i think it should
you know no no no no no no no no no no
no
no no i'm saying that's not realistic
right we can't do at this time we will
be able to do it but at this time we
cannot do compilation on demand so that
is not a workflow
that is interesting
why the whole
platform independence so right once okay
so
if we knew about the right tooling we
would be able to answer this question
of whether there is a thing you can
store which there probably is
the yeah i think i mean that's the whole
point of a lvm to have something that
can be run on the machine so
i don't see i mean it's true that i've
been surprised
um that if you copy paste the compile
code function here
um it's actually compiling again
uh but but i don't see anything on our
live stream is saying we should throw
out our max net and use pi torch instead
okay well it's the third time and we've
already changed three times
what what underlying framework we're
using so it's not obvious we couldn't
change again
and we certainly have thought about
supporting additional frameworks
it would be interesting to know what
would be involved in doing that
[Music]
a lot of work yeah i'm sure right
did you just why yeah why okay
well you for start we have we will have
to re-implement
all the layers in a new well of course
of course of course but that's
the the question is are those layers
compatibly implemented in different
frameworks presumably onyx
is an attempt to standardize what
happens
yes of course so my question is
yeah go ahead well it's not impossible
like we can absolutely
implement everything we have in pytorch
but before it's a lot of work and it's
always that's that's
when we originally picked mxnet after we
had used
what were the three things we used
before it i can't even remember all
right it was torch
and cafe yeah cafe keras
torch yeah i think not kira's but yeah
but we didn't use that okay
but yeah those were very very early days
and you know the framework was
was was forming so switching was not a
very big deal because there wasn't much
now it was a big deal it took months
okay
way more but you know i'm not really
believing this but but doesn't really
matter i don't think it matters
because i think that you know the
low-level implementation layer
is not the most important thing and in
the end that low level layer will just
go away
and it will be replaced by you know
going essentially from net function
down to whatever the the final uh
you know whatever the final compiled
code is
and you know in a few years that's how
it will work
so i'm not that concerned should we go
over the design i think the combination
by the way for people on the live stream
the reason we're not using those things
is because they were slower
i mean when we benchmarked them they
were simply slower
okay so let's and yeah that was a bunch
of reason for
internet it was working everywhere c
plus plus library
right and it was kind of alone
tensorflow didn't exist when we started
huh when it makes it no it didn't exist
it was just bad
it was not not yet when we started
starting when we started
six months in it appeared but it wasn't
working on on mac
yeah anyway um
all right so uh in a design so
whatever compiled thing with you i don't
believe in this i'm sorry this is stupid
no no no way what are you doing
here what is it what is this tuple thing
this is to
specify currently i mean not currently
that's a current plan
to have uh several arguments in a list
okay talk to the compiler people about
this yes we did we did we talked okay
why isn't there anybody here from that
group as i've said five times because we
talked about them a lot and and we
honestly
it's not gonna it's not gonna it's not
gonna fly that's not gonna fly
we don't know the exact design for that
they just told us that we'll provide a
way
um to to create a function that have you
know different type
in the same list because currently it's
one argument one type
right that can be a scalar it can be an
array but
is this an alternative is this
alternatives or is there no
no no no no it's a list it's a list it's
a heterogeneous structure
basically it's a struct basically
yes yes yes it's a list and then you
have you have here you have in that
example uh
array of rank one and array range three
all right let's take a look here
what are you doing here all right
so all right so so your idea here
is that you will simply have a compiled
layer
that takes this function inside now
remember that function
i could replace that function with a top
level function function
right now you don't know how to
implement that
but conceptually i could replace it with
that that is all the thing does
is it takes certain arguments and
returns a value correct
no there's there's information about
type
and about rank and this we use
uh as well they're very useful um
okay so hold on so hold on so you you
are getting meta information
from that compiled code function which
you believe you do not have
from an ordinary function again we
needed the compiler people and their
tooling
discussion because i don't think that's
correct i think we do have mechanisms
to get that kind of type information for
just a regular plain
top-level runnable function uh that
would be
the first first thing shapes you will
never have it until you define it
somewhere
it will rank until you define it
somewhere but wait a minute if the
function takes something of a definite
shape
then it will be specified if it takes
something of an indefinite shape
then it will presumably parameterize
what shape it can take
right so so first pin here is
that isn't right there should be a
wrapper that will work with an
ordinary function not a compiled
function here
but we'll we'll go past that right what
information exactly
you know what you know what i think
we're bordering a net function here
net function indeed can work with any
anything and we'll try to make it
automatic this is a low level thing
that's why i wrote the first thing low
level thing to convert wl code into
function compile it's not meant to be
the big
uh you know um so so it's a low level
stuff you just work with compile code
function
it's useful right now a bit more for
experts and it's going to be used inside
net function that is a real
uh you know there's a big guy so that i
mean that's that's our idea
i understand i understand i'm trying to
understand this design okay okay so as
far as i'm concerned
the inside of compiled layer is a
function that has
two attributes it takes values
and returns it takes inputs and returns
a value
thing number one just like an ordinary
function function
and second thing it has matter
information that you can extract about
types
is that correct yes it's correct okay
what exact matter information are you
extracting
are you extracting the same thing that
the compiler provides
not exactly right for example factory we
don't care
the type specific factor a we don't care
we just
need that it's an array we don't care if
it's effective so what you need to
define
very precisely is what information what
structure
do you get out of that compiled function
that represents the type information you
need
okay so you probably i'm sorry what rank
array wrong no no no no i don't want you
to tell me that i want you to tell me
what how it will be specified here right
in other words i want you to tell me a
structure
that you can extract from this compiled
code function that will probably be some
accessor of the compiled
code function information of compiled
code function comma something or other
that is exactly what you need it's
exactly that it's information of the
compiler functions
uh comma signature okay no no but but
not info
okay comma signature is that right yes
so it's exactly that exactly that right
nothing more nothing less
that correct what do you mean that's
exactly what well
in other words you have two things that
you're getting from the compiled code
function
one is its actual operation takes
certain inputs gives an output
and the second thing is the output of
information
compiled code function comma signature
is that right
yes okay that is it that's everything
you need well uh
are you sure material because signature
it does the rank and everything
yes okay okay let's take an example here
okay give me an example compiled code
function
uh well you can just run the first the
first term
function compile that guy
this is just a joke how long this takes
well
the very first time immediately i'm well
aware of how it works
right thank you
okay why is there nothing called
signature here
i'm not in charge of that okay so so can
you make sure somebody knows that that's
a bug
presumably yes okay
okay so how is this correct why does
that not have a typewrapper around it
this looks like a hacky thing that
wasn't documented right no
it doesn't have a type um ah okay type
dropper sure
yes that's wrong okay
so so let's discuss this for a second i
believe this was not documented
so can you please confirm that steven
stephen this is another
this is not a meeting this is another
topic i mean no no but i'm trying to
understand exactly what you're using
from here
right okay and you're telling me and if
you use some undocumented feature of the
compiler it's
it's not going to go well so let's make
sure that gets documented and i don't
want to find out there's a big trauma
because they fixed this to be correctly
designed and then all your code breaks
i am checking in checking argument okay
all right fine so
i think that's wrong so that should get
fixed okay i get it
so you're using these two things all
right now let's see how you use them
so you have a forward function a
backward function it is documented
it is documented in function compile
okay
where is it documented it's not
documented documented means it's
described at the top i'm not interested
in the fact that it's been stuffed into
some random example
but it's okay it's not okay let's not
talk about that anymore it's not for us
it's for compiled people we have a lot
of things to talk that are not about
compile
and i think that's what we should talk
about otherwise okay fine let's
get let's keep on keep going please
don't tell me it's documented it's not
okay so devin can you can you please go
make sure that that gets done
but it'll need a review because it's
obviously not too designed correctly
either
yep i got it okay let's look at this
all right forward function input goes to
output backward function takes three
arguments apparently
yes so it's a thing that
basically compute the input gradient
given all that stuff okay so is this
this can we do this
the automatic differentiation by default
we've met with robnapp today
and it seems that we'll be able to do it
in the future he's working on something
wait wait wait wait wait wait what are
you exactly are you saying
are you saying that given a compiled
code function with all the things the
compiled code function could have in it
which includes all kinds of wacky you
know functions and
special functions with branch cuts and
who knows what else we can do automatic
differentiation
of those it seems very implausible to me
not in
every case of course okay so then
explain to me what you mean
i mean that okay you mean that sometimes
we might be able to do it in the long
run there will be
some numb fraction of cases in which it
will work and
sometimes it will say sorry i could not
automatically differentiate this
so let me understand what the top level
functions that do automatic
differentiation look like
if i'm not mistaken we could take a
function function
and we could do automatic
differentiation on it right
yes okay do we have that code
it's it's it's not in production yet
it's i mean you have this code so
you can take a function function and you
can generate from it
and automatically differentiate the
version of that function function is
that correct
yes a function which which takes we give
you gives you the gradient of the first
one yes that that's
that's what's the the claim okay right
so then we we need a
a function called automatic
differentiate or some such other thing
automatically
such other thing which takes a function
takes a function function here
and returns another function function
right
it also takes the you know
it takes another it takes the input the
output gradient
basically which uh rob knob was calling
it
uh no no no no no no no i'm saying it
does the automatic differentiation so it
may have to take some additional
arguments
to say what it's differentiating with
respect to although i doubt that because
i think before
it also takes it also takes an another
array so so basically it could be an
argument of
the output function as well it depends
yeah so but but anyway you need
it's more general than that that is
basically okay
but so that function we need that
function
because that function is the function
that you are implicitly calling internal
to compile layer in the case where the
second argument is automatic
unless we unless we have that function
explicitly it will be toast
because you know if we have that
function explicitly people can check
does this function automatically
differentiate
right otherwise it's totally bizarre
you're running feeding it into compiled
layer
as a kind of a a throwing a dart and
seeing whether it happens to work
right yeah of course i mean if the
automatic differentiation failed
compilation
no no no i'm not interested in that i'm
saying we need a function
that will do automatic differentiation
you give it a function it produces the
automatically differentiated function
you need the functionality yes
of course no no we need that function
not just the functionality we need that
function right okay we're not just
putting it in as an automatic hack
inside compiled layer
of course not yes okay and that function
needs to work
on top level functions as well as
compiled code functions
right that's not really for me and i
will not be developing that
everything we we cared for i don't care
i'm we're talking about design
i'm telling you from a design point of
view this function needs to work on top
level functions
as well as on compiled code functions
okay cool now i think you're going to
tell me
that you need more meta information
about the function to be able to do this
and that's where we have to worry about
what do we do in this automatic
differentiation thing with respect to
that signature
thing and so on right and that's why
it's going to get a little tricky
but we need to resolve that because
that's necessary for this design
uh we can't help it i don't think it's
necessary for this
agreement i agree with mateo i don't see
in the workflow or it's useful look your
compile layer compile function automatic
it's going to go wrong it's going to go
with you it tells you it's so wrong
it tells you it tells you it cannot do
automatically we're going to go it's
going to go wrong it's going to be a
throwing darts thing
it's not going to work in practice but
what is what is i don't understand okay
so
the reason the reason i'm saying that is
it is not a good idea to have something
there's a piece of functionality that is
being used automatically here
it is automatic differentiation that is
a piece of functionality it's a factored
piece of functionality
right now you are implicitly calling it
as part of some function that does a
whole bunch of other stuff
yeah yeah right it is wrong to not
factor it out
yeah okay okay no i think it's a cool
thing to have i think the automatic d is
a good thing to have is gonna be useful
uh i completely agree the company agreed
okay fine so let's understand because i
think they're gonna be some bumps
in designing that and i want to
understand those because i think those
bumps
are going to bite us in compiled layer
if we don't deal with them automatically
but
what robin up is working on is you know
okay is he here
no i don't think so but he i mean can we
get
him it's not something that is just
intended to be used internally for us i
mean it's of course he will expose it
honestly we have a lot to figure out we
have a lot to figure out this is
okay you know okay so listen listen
listen listen listen
look i'm telling you you need this
function you need to figure out
with rob a proposed design for this
function once you have that proposed
design
most likely it will just be compiled
layer comma automatic
although it might say compile layer
comma automatic d i have no idea um
that that that does this okay
but i understand this idea so what what
does this mean the backward function
takes the output what does that mean it
takes the output
the output of the layer so your layer
input output
okay and the arguments are it just it is
more convenient we could actually
recreate the output by calling the
forward function but
no i think it's not a good well but
again we need to understand this because
automatic d will produce a function
which has the same
argument structure right yeah uh i think
it could produce many functions
one could just be the gradient you know
something that uh
this is a particular choice of backward
function
exactly automatic d this is a good point
we should basically so we have put that
output argument there
because you know since right now the
user is supposed to try to
implement that function and it might be
useful to save time and use the
pre-computed output sometimes you
you need it you know you you want it but
what i just said
is when you do automatic differentiation
the the result
will not have that second argument it
has no idea about that
so what we should do is that and we we
already
evaluated this with the we should
reverse the second and third argument of
the backward function and make the third
argument optional
yeah i don't know i'm not sure about
that but i think either way
you're going to have to end up with some
kind of curry weirdness
from that automatic d to get this thing
that's why i'm telling you you've got to
design automatic d
okay then all of this will be clear once
you've designed everything we care about
that is that that process produces
another compile code function and i
understand but it's one it has to be one
with the correct argument structure
of course it is it's it's the child of
the function we're differentiating
of course i understand but automatic d
does it take
arguments right is it f prime you know
is automatic d
essentially f prime if not
what is it it's f prime
it's a tensor contraction of f prime
with another tensor i mean
okay which for us is the output gradient
no no
no you see i understand i understand
that that's what it is but
but this is when you have that's the
whole point of factoring
this automatic defense automatic d will
be more general
us we have a specific case and we know
exactly the case it's minimizing the
most function
the the this is called automatic
dimension not bad propagation in our
case it is back propagation
because we are differentiating a
function that has only one
output the loss so we always go from the
loss to the bottom it's always
until you end up with something which
has two loss functions which sometimes
happens
yeah okay it's two but yeah yeah you
found them you sum them you take
some weighted average so well i
understand but i'm
i keep on telling you okay look
just you know just design
automatic d it will be obvious what to
do if you have that design
yeah okay and and i think it is this
isn't
you know this is probably close but it's
not quite right um
all right okay so this is already so
support port name okay so this is okay
so this is something purely for the
compiler group
this hasn't with you exactly with
supporting
ask them we ask them provide us a way to
you know
that's not going to be it maybe not
actually i don't know
that name is not the right name okay i
just wrote that as
obviously that name isn't the right name
i think you have a function called
tuples that does something completely
different
sure sure i mean okay so it's not the
right name so i mean
you know we agree we agree we don't want
to propose a name for that
we you know whatever it is combined type
or something so
i understand but but but you're trying
to do a design review
and you're showing me things that are
that
you know are just obviously wrong okay
we agree this is going to be done by the
compiler group which for some reason is
not represented here
okay all right let's keep going down
here
oh boy oh boy
is for us input port output ports so
that's a way to specify names or shapes
or both uh for the ports
i understand let's understand what the
actual
function so normally you know what we've
done
which has become something of a hack
tower is
we have i mean okay so our normal way of
dealing with named
arguments named inputs named outputs is
with associations
but in the neural net framework we have
a slight weird side generalization of
that
so i mean in this case what is this
actually doing
this is saying the the previous
layer was generating what amounts to an
association
containing port 1 and port 2
right and that is going to be
be packaged in a certain way to be fed
to this compiled function
is that correct uh yeah so
it defines so so you can use this
compiled layer by giving an association
um exactly one key so i mean but but the
the bottom line of what this weird input
ports function
option option would be and it shouldn't
be an option
right is this is the thing that is
taking whatever is coming from the rest
of the net
flow so to speak and packaging it
in the form that is used by the function
inside compiled layer
correct and to refer to this board
you know to do net extract to do to to
do a bit of primary
say connection second what do you need
to do for that this this is
so is it the case then that you can i
thought this compiled layer was just a
blob of lvm code
it is not something where you can ask
information questions like what are the
weight values for this or that thing no
it is it is because he's a citizen of
the framework and it has all the
properties that yeah
how can that can ask for the shape you
can ask for
but you can't ask for weights can you
well
that that's that's that's another story
right it doesn't make any sense right
principle you can
you we have a design to add weights to
to this compilation but that's another
story i think it's another story it's
not relevant to this
that's a that's something where you
might have meta information and again
the compiler tooling framework
allows you to store matter information
where you might store some meta
information about the weights possibly
although that sounds
complicated to me because the weights
are either in compiled code or they're
not in compiler
we shouldn't be using compiler
structures for that this is a citizen of
the framework
and the framework already has those
concepts built in every layer
has a you know sports every
with names wait wait wait wait wait i'm
not talking about the ports i'm talking
about weights
yeah other influencers yeah layers
can have also weights inside okay okay
so so what i'm saying is
the things that information supports for
layers
only some of them are supportable for
compiled layer and that's okay
right one of those things
yes yes right because it you can't get
weights out of a piece of llvm
code no no no that makes sense doesn't
make sense doesn't make sense right
okay so in this case what you're doing
is
this is essentially providing wrapping
to which is whose goal is to take the
structure
that is coming into this compiled layer
and package it up so that it is correct
for this
internal function okay so in other cases
you know there are other net layers that
don't know
the shape of their inputs and so on is
that true or is that not true does every
other layer
in its very nature define the structure
of its inputs
a threading layer you you have you don't
know how many points you have
and we have the same by the way the same
option will be used in 3d layer
and in a few other layers which i forgot
the name
template
so this is this is saying
okay so option inputs arrow n comma
exactly fix the number of inputs we want
to remove that
you want to remove that and go and use
input okay i don't think we should
call it input ports i don't think that's
the right concept right
so what you've got here is and you've
got a couple of different uses here
right what you've got is essentially a
specification of
either arrays homogeneous arrays
or associations right homogeneous
uh no no different length it's it's a
list of shapes like port one
is a three by four or two is a two by
three okay that's fine but
it's list of dimensions list of
dimensions i understand but but in a
sense what you're doing here
is you're defining what are the possible
part numbers
you've been given a blob of stuff as
the input to this layer right this is
defining what are the conceivable part
numbers
in that blob of stuff right the
association specifications the
the range of indices of numerical
indices etc right
yeah okay so as i understand it
the i mean right now the top level can
be a named port
or it can be i mean in this case right
so you've got these cases here
right except that to be more realistic
we could do something
totally weird like that couldn't we or
could we not
yes it just uses automatic naming for
the names you don't provide
and the automatic naming is numerical by
by position is that correct
yes okay
so let me just try to understand what
this is so and this has been used
elsewhere in the framework this is
this is the mechanism by which you know
in a sense
every neural net layer is given some
structure that structure might be a
thing that says
port one arrow and then it might be a
you know whatever it is
thing whatever you know some shape here
or it might say i mean in in in general
this is the same kind of stuff
that you might feed into put into a data
set
right it's a it's a it's a in principle
even the lower levels can be
associations is that true
uh no it's lower you you mean internally
well
it's only a raise it's only a race so
it's just so currently
currently although that may not survive
yeah you know in general we could have
something which is
the same thing as the innards of a data
set
that is mixed lists of associate lists
and associations
one day one day so the issue is that we
do not have
a generalization of dimensions for the
cases that we're describing here
right we don't have one for this case
here and we don't have one for this mix
in other words if you say what's the
shape of a data
yeah it's a tough thing you know it's
tough problem well
let's go for a long way too long it's
interesting yeah
that's right so what it is okay however
the compiler
is going to need that if it doesn't
already have it in some way
because it needs to know the shape of
everything it's dealing with
it is not a shape-shifting not lizard
but
uh it needs no to know the rank
not the shapes currently i mean uh yeah
the way it works is
you see you just have machine integer
one machine integer three
it doesn't have to have the exact shape
just the
the rank the number of
axis number of levels say that again
it's just the number of levels that it
needs uh the compiler
but but no but array depth okay
i'm not sure that's necessarily correct
so it doesn't need to know the explicit
dimensions is what you're saying
the compiler no no this is just for us
to do in france on the network
and although the compiler needs a
different thing which is it needs to
know what the what the final types are
down at the lowest level
exactly yes exactly final types and
array depth
okay but here now do you always need to
know
the actual or can one of these be
automatic and the lowest level depth and
some
i thought in some in some layers the
lowest levels
yeah okay specify that do you specify it
with an automatic there are you just
specified in a different way
yeah no you can do automatic means it's
not specified okay but is that the only
specification you can give for that
for that case it's either
well variable as well exactly you can
use variable length which means
what does that mean that means that
how do you write it uh it's very it's a
string called bearing
or a string oh my god
okay but this is something that is
it's a hack but it's also you cannot do
it at any dimension
yeah you can only do it at the first
dimension correct and you can put it
only once
uh you cannot have like varying varying
uh
okay in the model of design
in which the question is in which you
have a boat
and you know the boat is gradually
taking on water
this is a time when you really have to
start up the pumps in a very industrial
way
okay we need to actually figure out how
to do this design this is a mess
i mean okay you're talking about future
things like like
um you know we don't need to handle
nested association no i understand that
but i i
i okay here's what i think i think
um in the discussion that we were having
about um insertion
and array reduce and all those kinds of
things right
we had this concept of a um
[Music]
what was this concept the concept of um
um
oh gosh what is the idea here um
uh the thing we were discussing about um
named mapping onto
how did this work this is i'm
i think this is the same idea i think
this is the this is a
related to that idea and since i can't
completely remember what we had figured
out
the name levels
yeah yeah right right exactly exactly
that's what it's about naming levels
right the generalization of association
that allows you to name levels
i think okay this is
a related question i think
um maybe not but it's
i think it's um i mean look what this is
this is a way to generalize dimensions
for these more complicated structures
and
again it's exactly what you need for the
compiler
yeah it's it's extension of a type
system that's uh
something i need as well for my data
processing uh
thing that we use for automatic machine
learning and um
right many places and that i said
there's a lot of in a lot of places we
have recreated this type system and and
uh
right but i mean so this is a particular
need of a generalized dimensions
that can represent the shape of
something now what you're going to do
here
is what you're saying is this is the
shape that's coming in
right this is the shape to expect this
compiled layer expects this shape
now what is not obvious to me is that
shape has to be
repacked into the raw shape that is
going to be fed to the compiled function
is that true or not true in other words
the comp either the two possibilities
either the compiled function
has a type declaration that represents
the shape
in which case that it has that go ahead
it does i mean you don't specify shape
you don't just be display the depth
and that's it so so we are not
contradicting what
what we say to the compiler we're just
adding extra information i i know but
but so
that information should be addable in
the structure that represents in other
words when you say
i have an array i think we already have
a mechanism for saying i have an array
of length more than three
we certainly need some stuff like that
um
we have some of those mechanisms and so
what this is doing is
we say we have a an array which is
concretely of length
three for example
i'm saying and i think that should be
part of the type specification for an
array
you can say it's an array of of
arbitrary length or it's an array of
this specific length and i believe there
is already a mechanism for doing that
okay so i i think whatever this is
you're saying but the declaration in
here
does not need to be as specific it
doesn't need to know the
the the um it only needs to know the
depth of the array not the size of the
array correct
that's what you're saying okay but
nevertheless in this
so what you're saying is you could have
a generic
um the uh
uh you could have something um
uh generic yeah bob is commenting it
sounds like a dependent type system we
have a very elaborate dependent type
system that's what all of these
these these kinds of constructs are
about but yes
this is actually something a little bit
beyond what's normally done there
i mean the problem is look yeah the pro
the problem is the type system rapidly
becomes universal
at which point you can no longer do type
inference because you don't have
decidable
results in it et cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera et cetera so it's a
it's a complicated issue of how you have
something which is both
broad enough to be useful and not so
broad that you can't do type inference
anymore
um or that you have something which we
have had trouble with
where the type inference is a giant
piece of theorem proving code basically
um this is like the um
anyway okay all right so let's go back
to this so what this is doing is
inside the compiled function is the type
specification
now you want to like a
cell exposing you know
various molecules on its surface so to
speak
you want to expose certain aspects of
that internal type information
at the level of the layer without going
into the internal compiled function is
that correct
yes because this this information will
almost all be replicated in the type
specification for that internal function
is that correct why replicated because
because you have to tell it this
information is telling you
what shape to expect for the compiled
function is it not
they don't overlap exactly why not for
example
the so in the in the compile function
you
you care about real 64
versus r32 okay but in the layer at the
layer level you don't
there's only reels and and
and in in in the opposite direction at
the layer level you care about the shape
okay this is a mess you don't yeah okay
okay but that's not a reason to
replicate the information twice
right you're saying that there are
slight differences in what is relevant
to declare i mean
we're replicating we're adding
information no
but you have a structure that is pretty
that is that has a lot of the same
information in it
but what you're saying is the compiler
okay so here let me let me summarize
the compiler is more specific about the
types
saying real 64 instead of just real less
about the shape yeah
and less about the about the shape not
in the well not shape but
actual dimensions concrete dimensions
yeah yeah right
i agree that some information is
duplicated but
you know these this is separate systems
which were conceived
by separate people don't give a damn i
don't give a damn
that's not the right argument the right
argument is that input ports output
parts are not made
for a custom compiled layer only
it's made for all the other layers so so
this is just
come up in this meeting because that's
kind of the first time we went to here
but we add the same thing for um
anyway a bunch of other videos okay so
so essentially what you want to do
is this is another type system
basically that is saying what shape
what shape of thing to expect for this
layer
because you want to know that at the
time where you're setting up the network
right if it wasn't for that you could
just do it on the fly and you just see
what you get
and set it up but you need to know it at
the time when you're setting up the
network because you need to train the
network
sometimes you need sometimes sometimes
you don't uh
by the way we already have that with
just input
so if you get a linear layer you can't
specify
the shape of the input i know it's
always been always been very confusing
to me i mean this input and output
as strings it's our mechanism it's
actually
yeah it's actually port names i think we
shouldn't see it as input output is just
portland it could be full
you specify the port so that's a
different mechanism than what you've got
here here you've you've put the input
ports in the list and you can change the
name yes yes you can change
it that's why i put a single argument
case you could also use that to just
rename the input
port of inelia for example okay but i'm
okay
okay so look what we're doing right now
is
if we say something like linear layer
right what we say right now is input
arrow
and then the shape basically isn't that
correct yes
but when i say shape i don't really mean
shape i mean actual dimensions
dimensions yeah dimension right you
could also put it in an encoder you can
put
um yeah what can i put there a net
encoder which
can put a net encoder and what does the
net encoder say in terms of shapes
it has well-defined shapes depending on
the settings and the type of the encoder
and blah blah blah
but wait wait so so this thing here
stands for something which knows that it
will return a four by five array is that
correct
yes okay
all right so right now what we're doing
is we are putting
into the layers directly port numbers
port names and their shapes
yes right okay so it is not only defined
names this is not defining board names
in that case linearly
already as a port calling i understand
it knows about that port
that is that is one of its it's uh uh
you know that's basically just filling
in that argument
okay
so
um okay
let me think about this for a second so
so what you're saying is
and what's this could have weights
inside the layer
wait a minute so
this layer
i see yeah this layer
might have parameters how would the
parameters en entwine
themselves into i mean the obvious way
to do it would be
that one of the arguments to i mean that
the arguments to the functions here
are partly rapid change you know
actual running on actual data and partly
slow
change learned yes
learn functions right yes you see the
signatures there forward function now
there is an additional argument which is
called weights and also for the backward
this is one possibility the other
possibility
is we don't change anything and we
define
weights as we do in that function with
net array layer
so basically it's an input as any other
input or forward function about what
functions yeah i understand
and um there's a little bit of
technicality
if we do that uh maybe a little bit more
all right so listen listen we need to
wrap this particular meeting so so
look let's summarize where we're at okay
first you've got to learn about this
compiler tooling things
okay second of all we've got this
weird thing here which is going to
require another discussion next time
let's make sure we have the compiler
people and
rob knapp here so that we can have a
real discussion about this
and also about the actual automatic
differentiation mechanism
right all right so i mean
the uh is there something you're trying
to get into 12
2 well input ports input ports output
ports i think that's the main and and
actually
i mean compiled later but it will be
experimental
this has got several more hours of work
to do on it
in terms of design and it needs to have
the right people this is not one of
these cheap design
type things it's going to be somewhat
complicated
i mean in the end we may be able to have
a design for
this it will not look like this
um but it may have something which is
you know
basically the equivalent of this
um
but you know we need to know where it's
going before we can elide it
down to whatever it is that is the
convenience syntax
and um you know for that the main thing
is specifying generalized dimension type
constructs
and for that it will be useful to know
both the compiler type specifications
and the data data set
type specifications which are not
exposed but they may have something
useful in them
that make sense
yeah yeah sorry i mean this was
hoping it would go easier yeah well so
was i
i thought i thought i could be late for
this meeting because this meeting would
be like 10 minutes and we'd be done
yeah um sadly not not so
all right get get another thing on the
calendar and um
we will continue we will solve this it's
it's
and in the end hopefully um
uh
um
yeah ethan is commenting that function
compile can't compile to gpu code
i don't know again we don't have people
from the compiler group so i don't
really know the answer yeah
at some point it will like the function
compile
the idea is to have it compiled to cuda
now and there shouldn't be a fundamental
problem with that because the llvm
that's a
back-end llvm code generation problem
that
you know is being solved elsewhere
all right for people who are on this
live stream we're actually going to go
to another live stream in just a moment
here
um talking about a utterly different
subject
oh geometric scenes
um all right so all right to be
continued let's get another one of these
meetings in the next few days
um and uh we'll come up with a good
solution
um all right